okay Hadi so we are working in this
field of AI for a couple of years now
but it seems that you know AI is always
exciting but it became even more so
recently so what are some of the things
that really get you like interested and
even more and more excited about the
future right now yeah I know the past
like year couple of years I've been very
very exciting uh in this field like we
we hope we are observing really really
powerful AI models
um whether with you know charging PT and
large language models recently uh and
even like slightly before that with like
this amazing diffusion models that allow
us to like amazing generative AI models
that allow us to like very easily
generate super highly realistic images
uh with the very very you know easy way
with just like textual prompting you can
now any one of us very easily interact
with these models
um and generate amazing images you want
the image of a dog you know on in New
York on a skateboard that will give you
an amazing you know uh image super
realistic
um
and you can imagine how what amazing
stuff you can do with this basically
translating our imagination and
everything that we think of into actual
images and maybe in the future videos as
well it's it's really awesome like this
is very very exciting for me so just
walk me through so essentially like
imagine I am an artist or I'm not an
artist I just I just want to I have a
hobby or I just want to have a nice
illustration for my Christmas card I
just type in what I want and one of this
model just gives it to me yeah exactly
like previously like you have to like
maybe learn Photoshop like to to create
like an amazing you know nice like a
very like a very nice photo or like you
want to like you should hire someone to
like create like a nice card for you for
Christmas for example or like any other
celebration like now you just like
whatever in your mind you just talk to
the computer literally talk to these AI
models tell them I want the image of a
blah on the blood like you can create
whatever you want literally uh with the
very very easy like everyone can do that
this is the amazing thing like it's
super easy and super good like it's
amazing how good it is right now
so you mentioned Photoshop so it's not
only about like creation something
completely new but you can also modify
existing photos yeah definitely
certainly like these models are not only
about generating things from scratch in
your imagination you can actually bring
photos like the photo of you and your
wife you would like to go to Hawaii for
example but you don't you can't afford
that for example you can just like Photo
like Photoshop that in a very easy way
right now like you don't have to know
anything about Photoshop you can create
amazing photos you can edit your photos
with your wife or with your friends
um in a very super realistic way and
very easily you just specify oh this is
the photo of me and my wife and I want
like to change the background to be you
know in in Maui
or Hawaii or anywhere like anywhere in
Hawaii for example anywhere in the world
you will do it immediately like in one
second literally it's amazing okay so
that's super exciting I'm sure my wife
will be excited about this as well she
will definitely prefer that to actually
go into Hawaii so but like now that
starts to get maybe too worried right so
essentially like we are not used as a
society to this kind of you know ease of
creation of like very realistic images
or modifications of images that anyone
can do so aren't you worried about that
a little bit yeah it's certainly amazing
but also like certainly like uh like
very risky and like it definitely
worries me like although we can like do
amazing stuff with it we can also like
do amazingly good bad stuff with it like
we can we can easily like imagine now
people using this these tools to like
create you know fake images spreading
them online spreading misinformation uh
they might create you know a fake image
of some explosion somewhere which would
which will cause like you know stock
markets to react to the to this to this
you know fake fake image or video it
will cause like maybe tension between
countries and even on a more mundane
level like people might be able to like
can can right now manipulate others
people like their friends or their like
other people's images in a bad way and
maybe like blackmail them if they are
actually about people
um to give them money otherwise they
will spread these you know maliciously
modified or edited images all of us have
images online right now right so like
everyone literally if there's a
malicious actor
without any experience with a Photoshop
or anything they can bring these images
download them download them from
wherever they are
um using use this AI models to edit
these images maliciously make us look
very bad make us do something that's
like we don't want to do
um and then blackmail us to actually you
know give them money otherwise they will
spread so it's pretty risky like there's
so many things that can go wrong with
this with this technology basically okay
so that's a lot and actually quite this
case let me unpack of this so first of
all you mentioned kind of you know kind
of coming up with some fake image or
some explosions actually recently this
happened there was an explosion well
purported explosion at Pentagon that
kind of went on Twitter and now it's X
and essentially this caused some ripples
before people realize this is this is a
fake image but like what you are saying
is actually even more even more
malicious and even more inside you so
you are saying okay now if I want to
take any photo of let's say you online
you know you have it on Instagram on
Twitter on your web page and then I can
use it using this AI advances to create
like to put you in some compromising
situation and like I say look Hadi if
you don't pay me this much of a Bitcoin
I will just put it around and yes you
know this would be a fake photo but you
know just the damage of you having to
explain it to everyone and so on just
maybe not worth it you say okay I will
pay you and of course it might not work
if actually you know if I am your friend
because then you know who I am and there
will be a lot of social costs but I
guess you can imagine that like scammers
like professional scammers can just do
it online like you can do this at scale
because you essentially don't need human
interloop in that and essentially that's
something that happens yeah yeah I think
like this like doing it at scale is part
in particular very dangerous like before
like if there's a malicious actor they
have to like be very professional you
know at Photoshop Etc and like they have
to do it like one image at a time or
they have to recruit many people to do
it now a person a single person's a
single malicious actor can do it at
scale that can modify the images or edit
maliciously the images of thousands of
people immediately this is very
dangerous like it's it's ease of use
it's a scalable nature is it makes it
actually in particular uh you know um
dangerous and in a much more serious way
than like what how Photoshop is
dangerous for example yes so I
completely agree with that actually like
I was testifying in Senate and one of
the other witnesses there was actually a
woman who was essentially you know she
was a victim of a scam based on
essentially like someone called her and
played to her the clip of her daughter
saying okay I got kidnapped and then
they kind of these people say okay you
need to give us Ransom otherwise
something will happen to your daughter
of course as you can imagine this was an
extremely traumatic experience
except and that's the good part is that
it turned out that her daughter is
totally fine and this clip of of her
daughter kind of saying that I was
kidnap was actually faked using AI so
this is kind of a bit more
individualized effort but yes above the
kind of things that we use to trust
implicitly now we need to learn not to
trust and again this scale of it that's
something that makes me worried quite a
bit as well so future is green
is there anything we can do about that
it's a very very serious problem and
that's why we like we have to do
something about it and that's what you
know why we are trying to do something
about it and this is exactly what we try
to do in our you know recent project
um uh Recent research paper you know
photoguard uh we're trying to attempt to
like solve this problem we're trying to
see if there is anything that we can do
that we can do there
um so in this project what we try to do
or the idea that we wanted like to to go
after is like is there a way where we
can actually prevent this from happening
by you know
maybe modifying the image our images
that we upload online in a way such that
they you know hinder any attempts of
manipulating them by these models so
this is like the idea that like we were
thinking of like oh is there anything we
can do there
um and and indeed we tried indeed we
tried and we actually have something
that
seems to be working and it's a prototype
of course but like it's just like
shows that we have stuff that we can do
there we are able to like you know
protect our images in a specific way
yeah so let me kind of unpack it a
little bit so first of all you know
before we actually explain in more
detail what this is doing actually
there's a nice story about this so can
you kind of tell us how actually this
project came about because I think it
was pretty cool
you know I was I was watching like I'm a
big fan of Trevor Noah I was watching
The Daily Show
um you know before before it stopped uh
back like in in December
um and there was this like uh you know
episode with like with like Trevor Noah
interviewing Mira morati the CTO of up
in Ai and they were discussing basically
it was like the time where Dali 2 came
out and it's like an amazing you know
very powerful AI model for like
generating uh you know
uh images and also like it has the
capability of editing images
um it's one of these like very powerful
generative AI models so they were
discussing this and uh Trevor asked Mira
it was like he was like exactly
discussing this like oh this is amazing
but this is super scary like he was
literally mentioning all of these risks
that we were talking about we were
talking about right now and he was like
oh is there anything we can do and Mira
responded of course like we have to do
things and you know you know things
things have to happen and like uh
they're trying to do things Etc with
like what we're talking about maybe with
watermarking and other things
um but then I was like oh yeah I think I
know how to do the I know one way that
might be able to like you know fix this
problem
and we given that like we have worked a
lot on like you know adversarial
examples I got like this idea of like
why don't we use these things and I can
explain later as well what these things
are why don't we use this technology to
actually
protect our images like it might be
actually very easy to do that so that
that's where the idea came from I was
literally having dinner with my wife and
literally watching this episode and it
just came up with this idea okay so so
let's uh let's back up a little bit so
what we are trying to do in photoguard
is kind of develop this procedure for
kind of immunizing your photos that you
upload online from you know them being
edited using this AI models okay so
that's data somehow we would like to
make sure there is some like protective
coating that doesn't really change the
image to us and any humans looking at it
but somehow this AI models have really
hard time or it's impossible for them to
actually realistically change the image
so that's the goal so now you mentioned
these things called the theory example
so can you can you give us a bit of a
hint of What official examples are and
how they kind of fit the picture here
yeah totally so adversary examples is
like an interesting phenomenon in
machine learning uh it's it's these
small perturbations
which we can add to images which we feed
to our machine learning models which
will disrupt totally disrupt the machine
learning Model Behavior so for example
imagine you have the image of of a dog
okay and imagine there is a classifier a
machine learning model that recognizes
this dog with a very very high accuracy
it's amazing at recognizing this dog
adversary example an adversary example
is basically a small modification to
this image of a dog
which keeps it for us humans as the
image of a dog so for us humans we don't
see anything that changed it's small
changes in the pixels such that it
actually leads to an image which will be
recognized by this machine layering
model as totally different thing it will
think that this image of a dog which for
us humans looks like a dog is actually a
cat so the model will just like totally
misunderstand what the image is so
you're saying Okay so this example is
essentially this way in which you can
take an existing image and change it in
a way that is imperceptible to humans by
modifying the pixels a little bit so as
the any machine learning model that kind
of works with this with this image will
you know will kind of think something
different you can essentially like steer
the behavior of this model or disrupt
the behavior of this model on this image
okay how does it fit and it has been and
of course you can see how this is like a
dangerous thing like it has been always
been observed that adversary examples
are bad things right like uh we have a
machine learning model and people now
can actually attack it what we call
adversarial attack we can attack this
model by changing small you know by
doing small and perceptible changes to
the inputs of this model and can break
our model so it has always been to
observe that these things are bad things
what we did in our project and
photoguard is actually you know
repurposing these you know this
phenomenon to actually make it something
good this phenomenon examples is very
good at like breaking machine learning
models right so why don't we use it to
actually break these you know AI
generative models if they try to to
manipulate our images so that where the
idea came out from properly we know that
this tool exists this thing actually
this phenomenon sorry exists in machine
learning let's use it in the right way
let's use it to actually uh you know
uh reinforce what we want let's use it
to actually protect our images so let's
add this you know small adversarial
imperceptible perturbations to our
images before uploading them online such
that if they actually get passed by some
malicious actor to some diffusion model
so that they edit them they will not
work it will basically these
perturbations these small immunizations
that we add will would disrupt this AI
model so this is the the overall idea
basically I see so essentially we are
kind of using cellular perturbations as
a like this protect protective layer
because it will essentially like yes to
us humans this will still be the same
picture but any model that tries to act
on it will kind of get confused and not
work well exactly great so here we have
this this idea this solution so is it
ready to go like is it can we just start
using it right now
um so what we did is basically a
prototype as a research lab you know we
do prototypes and demonstrate that this
act this thing is actually you know uh
feasible to to actually it actually
disrupts you know existing models and we
actually got it to work we actually got
it to like disrupt you know a few open
source models you know stable diffusion
models but for this to actually make be
a practice solution there definitely is
like a couple of things that we need to
take into account and before of course
it's a tool that everyone can use so the
first thing is that
it's very important to actually make
these immunizations
robust to
you know
tampering attempts by malicious actors
I immunize my image and put it online
someone might actually attempt to remove
this reverse engineer this immunization
by doing some tricks you know like
cropping the image maybe like adding
something to it maybe filtering it uh
maybe like you know taking a screenshot
of it so we have to build these you know
immunizations uh to be robust to to to
such phenomenons so this is the first
the first thing that has to happen and
the second thing is that
once we immunize our images and put them
online we have
to
guarantee in some way that they will
work for future generation models like
they might actually work for current
models but we have to like we have to
have some way to make sure that if
there's a new model that will come in
the future these immunizations will work
for it so we have to like make them
future proof basically or forward
compatible with future models and for
this to happen
it's very hard to it's very hard to do
this thing as a user personally it has
to come from the actual developers of
these models because they are the ones
who know what the future models will
look like they can guarantee that these
immunizations will actually also like
immunize images against future models
that they will build so these are like
two of the core things that in my
opinion has to happen before this is a
practical tool okay so let's go one by
one so for this question of like being
resistant to tampering after the image
is put online like what can we do like
how how would you go about you know like
making them resistant to the Stamper
yeah it seems like a tough problem
but luckily we have a huge amount of
literature on
exactly solving this problem unlike
making but like in a different context
so there's like a few years of work on
exactly making adversarial examples
robust to such tampering effects so
generate generating robust adversarial
perturbations we can utilize all the
research that happens there to exactly
apply it to this problem and this will
actually like work like it's basically
the same phenomenon in a different
context so we are lucky to have like
this huge amount of work that previously
was like oh to make that tax robust but
now it translates naturally to making it
a defenses robust basically I see so
that's that's very like interesting so
people were working hard to make these
attacks even more nasty but we can use
them to make our immunization to be much
more nasty in a sense that like you know
essentially much much harder to a
counteract exactly that's great so now
let's talk about this other issue so we
are saying okay you know one thing
that's important to understand about
photoguard is that it's kind of it has
to know what kind of models we are
trying to you know we are trying to
protect affect the you know like the
image against and of course we might do
it for all the existing existing models
but you know there will be new models
developed in the future and there's no
guarantee that whatever we do at this
point we also work against them but what
you are saying saying oh that sounds
like a hopeless proposition and saying
okay maybe now our image is protected
but in two years it might not what you
are saying okay so one way to approach
this question saying oh actually any
legitimate developer of this model
probably you know is on board with
having this kind of protections work
because you know that's definitely not
against the business actually helps them
you know counteract some of the problems
there so you could actually imagine
there would be some cooperation of them
when they say to actually make sure when
they design the model that they new
models in release in the future are also
like you know essentially this is funny
that they make sure they are susceptible
to this perturbation which means that
this kind of protections will will
continue to work exactly exactly like
it's it's funny here that like now we
have the incentive to make our models
more susceptible to these you know
attacks or adversarial perturbations
which before we didn't want because we
want to make our robust our models
robust to these things but like in this
particular you know scenario situation
these companies uh have the incentive to
make their models you know non-robable
like breakable by these immunizations
like they have the incentive to do that
because if people want to use these uh
these these models in a good way to
manipulate these image images in a good
way they they must be able to but if
they want to protect their images they
also have to be able to do that and this
is like why uh like how these companies
can actually like get in there and like
provide these you know apis for example
to to immunize our images against their
uh their models basically okay so so I
guess the future would be that maybe
it's all happening automatically each
time you upload your image from your
iPhone it just happens in the background
and you don't as you don't have to think
about that so that's great that's a
that's a great vision that we might do
go towards but kind of I just wanted to
go back to one of the concepts that you
mentioned in the passing recently
because it's kind of complementary is
the watermarking so what is watermarking
and in what way it can help or not help
the scenarios and kind of how does it
differ from the type of functionality
that photograph wants to provide yeah
very good question so like watermarking
we're hearing about watermarking
everywhere in the context of you know
language models we want to mod Watermark
you know like the output of these models
so that we can track them uh we are
hearing about it also like in the
context of these diffusion models so
watermarking basically is a way where
you can where you actually add some you
know like
something to the image that's generated
by these models so that you can detect
that it's actually a fake image not an
actual real image and it definitely is
is a legit way to like go towards you
know so like keeping track of like what
images we are generating because it's
important that the images that we
generate or other people generate are
tracked whether they are fake or not
fake for many reasons like for for you
know like misinformation tracking for
like this perform many many different
reasons and this is a very very good you
know direction of course
um in the first from photoguard and the
fact that like it's comes like as in you
know a post like um
like it's not a preventive solution of
the edit from happening at the first
time it's like a post hoc maybe like
that's what you call like it's a
post-hoc solution like it comes
afterwards we generate a fake image and
now we can track it if it's we can
detect it if it's fake or not the
problem that might happen purely
detecting fake images can sometimes be
not enough for example if there is the
image of some explosion somewhere even
before it's flagged whether it's like
you know fake or not the effect might
happen already like stock markets might
might react like before even people
double check or you know fact check
whether it's you know fake or not
imagine there's like the the an edited
photo of a child in some school which
makes this child look embarrassed for
example the effect has happened already
before you know even even after you know
the school announces that oh it turns
out this is a fake photo so there's
there like preventing these edits from
happening at the first place was you
know one of our main goals as well in
this tool it's like
yeah it's a preventive measure compared
to like you know detective measure
measure basically and both of them are
complementary of course like if
something is not prevented hopefully we
can detect its basically sounds great so
essentially you are saying that like
it's like actually you could use both
like they're complementary the problem
with watermarking is that essentially
yes you can check that this photo is
fake
assuming you can do the watermarking
robustly enough but like the photo is
already there where we are trying to not
let the photo happen to begin with okay
so this is kind of all very interesting
and we are very kind of happy that we
can provide these ideas into the space
but like you know as you look at the
landscape moving forward like you know
are you optimistic where we are going
are you worried about where we are going
what are you what is your feeling here
AI as a field is moving very very fast
and like a year ago or two years ago we
didn't imagine that like the progress
will happen this fast whether it was
with these amazing General models or
even with like judge PT and like things
are moving very very very fast so it's
hard to predict what's coming next but
even without anything new coming next
it's already we have already like very
serious risks that accompany our AI
tools right now so I think a major
challenge is actually you know dealing
with the current technology as is
while thinking that like this is just is
just improving and improving in the
future more and more for example
one thing that I worried really about is
like the like
the open source nature of these models
open source is an amazing thing of
course as a researcher as a PhD student
I love it like you know I can like play
with these models like I have access to
everything but we can imagine that like
if these very powerful
generative models are accessible by
anyone to even train them very quickly
on like small machines on one GPU for
example then this problem is not
solvable anymore
like if we reach that situation no one
can solve this problem like that's
anyone in us and on his laptop can train
these amazing generative models in a way
that they you know fool whatever you
know immunization layers we have
and that's game over we like I don't
think there's a solution there anymore
so this is one of the things that is
very very risky in my opinion for
example I see so so just to actually
like so so that's an important point
that you make saying like kind of
implicitly in both actually both
watermarking and the you know and the
photoguard you know relies on the fact
that there are developers that are kind
of like legitimate and they are willing
to do the right thing implement the
watermarking implement photoguard but
now if everyone can train their own
model in the basement then you know
that's up to them if they are not
legitimate they will just do do all
these things you can have some law that
compels them to do it but in the end the
enforcement of that might be much much
harder much harder yeah so okay so it
sounds like it's a lot of exciting stuff
moving forward there's a lot of danger I
think our society has to think really
really hard about like you know what's
to come and as usual we might not be
able to predict all the implications
what's to come I think you know the
policy has to to catch up with this as
well this is no longer just something
that only engineer can solve but yeah so
I guess we will see what the next couple
of years will bring yeah very exciting I
like I'm super excited about what what's
coming next like as as an AI researcher
like I like like this is this is all
what like like what I like to do like I
just like to like develop develop these
models make them as part of powerful as
possible like I love doing that but at
the same time I also like worry about
like their implications so I work a lot
on like you know we as a team work a lot
like on you know making them robust
making them you know trustworthy making
them you know uh Deployable in a
confident way basically making us like
confident when we deploy them figuring
out like all of these questions it's
super exciting uh but also super super
challenging because like the
advancements in AI is moving really
really fast yeah well looking forward to
continue to work with you on just that
yeah thank you to for tuning in to the
discussion about photoguard I hope you
found it interesting uh yeah we're happy
that that you're listening to to our
discussion and if you have any questions
of course reach out thank you so much
for for listening